how's it going everybody so I recently
saw venom and I must say going into it
hearing all the buzz about it hearing
some reviews say that it's really bad
hearing some say that it's really good
it is really confusing so today I'm
gonna give you my review of the movie
from my own perspective of course this
is just my own opinion and you should go
see it yourself and form your own I'm
going to try and avoid all potential
spoilers that I possibly can
I will however be talking about the
length of some scenes so if that is a
spoiler for you you have been warned and
if you're new to my channel be sure to
hit that subscribe button what the
notifications turned on so you can stay
up to date with all things relating to
venom marvel and so you can be entered
in my giveaway I'm giving away a few
copies of Avengers infinity war on
blu-ray some special edition posters and
memorabilia as well and congrats to
Tiffany Smith for being the next winner
of our giveaway email me and we'll get
you your prize so overall I thought
venom was a really great movie I'm
definitely going to be seeing it again
but having said that there are
definitely a few things that I would
change so let's talk a little bit about
the bat and then we'll end on the
positive the first thing is not
necessarily a bad thing to everybody but
for comic fans it probably is the movie
does not really stick to any story
relating to the comics although they did
a decent job with Eddie Brock's
character venom primarily revolves
around Spider Man I won't say whether or
not spider-man makes a cameo but this
movie is all about venom and Eddie Brock
venom doesn't even have the spider-man
logo on his chest like he always does in
the comics but if you keep an open mind
going into venom and accept a new origin
story you can get past that the next
thing is venom kinda starts off really
slow but it is a new origin story and
they have to set up each character and
they have to explain what the symbiotes
are so although necessary they could
have introduced the Venom symbiote a
little bit sooner another thing is that
the supporting cast is kind of just
there I didn't really develop any kind
of connection with them or
only care about any other character
besides venom and Eddie which is fine
because that's what the movie is about
the last thing I would mention is that
the final battle scene is very
anticlimactic and it's kind of short
don't get me wrong it is very very
awesome
and entertaining I just wish it could
have been a little bit longer so blowing
past all the tiny things that I would
change let's talk about how awesome the
movie is for starters Tom Hardy does an
excellent job he does a great job at
playing Eddie Brock and he does a great
job with a dynamic between venom and
Eddie this leads to not only a dark
movie but also a funny movie now I've
heard a lot of reviews that say the
venom movie couldn't decide which
direction to go dark and serious or
funny but I think that is the direction
they decided to go instead of having it
be one or the other
they went with both and in my personal
opinion it turned out very well you have
dark moments where venom wants to bite
the heads off everybody in a room and
then you have funny moments where Eddie
freaks out that venom slash himself eats
people which actually leads to the next
point and that is that the movie is
really hilarious there's a lot of humor
in the movie that is delivered really
well there are a few corny jokes in it
but again they are delivered pretty well
there's also a really good amount of
action in the movie when venom and Eddie
finally do bond you're on the edge of
your seat the whole entire time the
movie is packed with both action scenes
and hilarious scenes while
simultaneously being able to deliver a
serious tone I've heard that some people
think that it leans too much towards the
hilarious side but I actually think it
does a good job at managing the
hilarious side up with the dark side
with the serious side all at once
so overall it was a really good movie
that I very much enjoyed I was
entertained the whole entire time I
loved the action scenes
I love the comedy scenes and I loved the
fact that venom just wants to eat people
the whole entire time but again this is
just my opinion I highly encourage you
all to go see the movie for yourself and
form your own opinion
[Applause]
don't listen to a review that says the
movie is bad and not go see the movie if
you want to go see the movie go see it
I personally am going to see it again
and if you happen to go see it as well
come back here and let me know your
thoughts if you have seen it let me know
your thoughts in the comments below and
don't forget to subscribe like and
comment so you can stay up to date with
everything venom and Marvel related and
be entered in my giveaway as always
thank you all so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]